what is happening reject nation it's
Greg out of here and I am John Humphrey
and I just realized I'm wearing a DC
shirt two things at once
Oh one at a time boy The Runaways for
Marvel it has a trailer out and I heard
some early responses for this series and
they're pretty damn good oh good it's
another show connected to the MCU
Marvel's making it more complicated to
all the other worlds we got you in the
movies we got you a Netflix we got you
on ABC now we got you on whoo you know
I'm interested to see what Hulu Marvel
looks like because I never thought I'd
say this but I feel like Marvel could
use a win right now and least in terms
of TV what are you talking about
defenders everyone loved it everything
humans set the bar and everybody also
loved Iron Fist
I barely know anything about this show
other than the plot about how it's about
a group of like superhumans
children really they know no way Wow I
think they band together because they
find out their parents are actually like
super villains oh of course
okay which is which is cool yeah screw
parents yeah parents suck don't have one
except for Gareth hood if you had parent
be happy and I I know Gregg Sulkin
do you do that's right we're talking
them for a few hours talked he gave us a
dating tips yeah yeah the guys are so
good-looking in person he's very sexy so
good I hope this is good for his
sneaking I have a hard time being around
him with other people like why are you
this I don't think I'll ever talk ever
the kids that know you when you're young
no one will ever know you like that
again don't give up on that young people
you gotta let us say I hope you've
learned an American accent and do the
teenagers the last thing they're
interested in is what their parents are
doing that's not true
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
why is my mom's first year
this is like a much more twisted version
of x-men or like a cult yeah
[Music]
that's me
[Music]
really
[Music]
okay interesting it definitely looks
different different yeah yeah it kind of
reminds me of yeah like a cross between
x-men and Buffy almost I didn't expect
to be intrigued but I am a little bit I
think the problem with the trailer is
I'm a little more interested in who the
parents are what is the origin of us in
our strange powers yeah I've seen that a
billion times now but yeah the whole
parents are like druid yeah because
they're like the villains of the show
and that makes for a really interesting
dynamic tone to have the kids be the
heroes and the parents be the villains
because that's an ongoing series right
there because you can't imagine that
kids like killing their parents so first
season finale they're just all in a row
with their feet on their parents throat
I don't know anything about the runaways
I don't I do I honestly haven't heard of
them until I heard this trailer but I
like that I'm appeal to about it is it
seems like everywhere where Marvel has a
new show their show seemed to have a
different vibe there's a consistency
with the look of the Netflix Marvel
shows it's like they usually change a
color palette around but there's still a
consistency in its look the movies - and
then a.m. and the ABC shows and now this
on Hulu has a distinct look to it yeah
and I'm really hoping they commit to the
darkness of the show that's what I don't
want them to hold back on I don't know
Hulu works I think they can be as crazy
and violent and sexual as Netflix can be
I think they can I think so hey if they
can bring the edge I mean this reminded
me in tone of more like a Fox family or
an ABC Family it doesn't know now I
think the trailer does yeah yeah but
because it's on Hulu I'm wondering like
well with all these dark elements you
have that play here how crazy can you
get do it with it yeah I would love to I
would love to see a show that's about
kids you know even though I know that
most of these actors are playing
it's exactly what I would like to see a
show where it's about kids as the main
characters that goes like crazy violent
or commits to the darkness of it
worse this could be sort of like a
mellow drill I Chi feel like it could
drift into soap-opera territory if
they're not careful yeah now like the
hula description such a high concept
pitch every teenager thinks that her
parents are evil oh it was like the cast
looks pretty good to me I don't really
know how detailed the characters are
whose accurate to what here cast looks
like it could be saw looks like a wide
variety of characters I feel like the
strength of the show could be in its
relatability yeah if they can really
commit if they can really find that way
to make all these characters relatable
to its offices you got a nun Samba here
of parents and you got an ensemble here
of protagonist people but what's cool
about there isn't more drawn to the
parents right now is because there's
supervillains but I'm sure when their
parents they seem like they're good
people
yeah what's the comfort oh I already
feel like the villains are multi-layered
yeah because of that that fact alone
this is some one minute trailer Gregg
Sulkin Zinn it so gooey an American
accent he pulls it off well buddy yeah
he does Oh your British accent that's
out Greg sounds I think we met him he
said he just got this role or something
yeah I don't know I don't pay attention
to when you talk I'm just looking at you
you're glowing I mean it's easy to get
lost in his eyes like I just nod your
head and then when you make him laugh
you're like huh I'm making him laugh
it's like if you could accidentally get
Lampard by a vampire that's what it's
like talking to Gregg's yeah it's like
before you know it and probably he
doesn't even intend to but you're under
his charm this video is dedicated to
Gregg Sulkin I made him laugh a lot but
he's a little more talented than me in a
lot of other areas that's that's a big
difference you know you can you can you
can blackmail him someday maybe we
should ask him to come on the show only
do reactions with us and not once talked
about right see man you follow me
it's hard being an actor isn't it yeah
this is always auditioning and never
booking anything don't worry one day
you'll get a break don't worry you'll
get you got I believe it up keep it up I
see potential subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bow
followed at John Humphrey on Twitter
turn I think I imagine the Instagram
follow us on Twitter ground I'm at the
Greg album to face I am I'm the lesser
of the Craig's